Chris Rock is finally addressing the
slap hurt all around the world yes when
Will Smith slapped him across the face
at the Oscars after he made a joke about
Jada Pinkett Smith that's right and in
typical Chris Rock Fashion he joked
about the incident during his show in
New Jersey over the weekend according to
US Weekly Chris told the crowd anyone
who says words hurt has never been
punched in the face
ouch but then Chris insisted I'm not a
victim MF
and for those wondering how Chris was
affected by the whole incident he admits
yeah that bleep hurt MF but I shook that
bleep off and went to work the next day
I don't go to the hospital for a paper
cut listen that was not a paper cut that
was a Mohammed slab that uh you know
Will Smith was trained to do many many
years ago that was like a soap opera
slap but actually real it wasn't you
know they like wind up yeah you know
it's funny because I mean this was a
massive show Madison Square Garden with
him and Kevin Hart and Chappelle showed
up controversy there as well uh so I
understand that like when you're in that
environment that you kind of want to
just be I mean everything's been upbeat
for him in terms of his career yeah he
has a new girlfriend like things are
good friends like yeah but I I still in
my mind and I said this when this first
happened was that I think he is about to
sue somebody I know it's been a while
but I think there's some weird process
that he's going through and I you think
so I think so I still don't think he
really acknowledged the slap I mean he
made a joke about it at Madison but I
still think he's in a position where
he's trying to figure out how because I
don't think he's going to lay this down
just like that yeah I did I think he's
just gonna he just wants to brush it
aside I think he's probably just so over
it he doesn't want to become no to
become known for
being the guy who got slapped at the
Oscars and the more I think you go
through these litigations and go through
courts and do these lawsuits that's what
you will become and at this point he's
he looks really good but on the other
side it's taking ownership of the story
because what the Oscars did was allow
that to happen they allowed Will Smith
to stay in the room after what he did
and that's a no that is and so you need
to if you're in that position you are
able to change that storyline and that's
the power he has so I still think well
let's betuni that he is going to
potentially
sue somebody or bring this up and away I
see more of like an Oprah tell all sit
down happening and that's kind of how he
takes ownership over that story versus
like I'm gonna Sue Will Smith for blank
and blank amounts Oprah talkers getting
millions millions I'm sorry I'm just
saying I'm just saying just saying it's
a it's a tricky situation but like we
said he has a girlfriend like well now
life is good yeah you know the past is
the past yeah and sometimes you just
have to leave the past in the past but
I'm curious to see what happens at the
Oscars I know going forward like a lot
of people are saying that are they going
to ask him to host the next uh Oscar
which would be really smart on their
part and yeah like would he do it I
don't know if he would uh uh if Chris
does nothing he is empowering more
slappers uh BB Bean says that yeah I
think that he needs to own it a little
bit more it's almost like you can't
brush this off I think will needs to own
it a little more will was the one who
did the slapping Christmas just slapped
doing his job will
Mr Will Smith big Willy style yeah I
think you need to come out and do more
and so Fellini says uh I'm sorry if I
said you're not a name wrong uh let us
remember that he was disrespectful to a
man's wife punching the crap out of a
man that has previously disrespectful to
one's wife he got what he deserves so
people are still having the debate if
you if he was wrong or right violence is
never the violence is never the answer
yes ever he could have shouted will did
not need to jump on that stage and slap
somebody he could have said shut up man
or something from the crowd and that may
have been assigned to Chris on that
stage like okay this isn't going over
well you know I know this it's gonna go
on I think I I just I think he's going
to do more with it we will see and we
just remember we have it on film we bet
two dollars yes